dieser reise will helfen krisen zu
überwinden
hier in der wüste negev im süden israels
kommen jugendliche aus konfliktgebieten
zusammen um gedankliche mauern
niederzureißen
am anfang steht ein schnellkurs im bauen
mit lehm zu gast sind sie in einem
kibbuz hier hat man sich der ökologie
verschrieben gebäude aus lehm sind ein
teil des konzepts schon geht's los
gemeinsam sollen sie hier ausgerechnet
eine mauer bauen aber eine die sie
einander näher bringt das programm heißt
der mauern bauen mauern eingelassen wo
ich herkomme da gibt es eine zehn meter
hohe mauer die katholiken von
protestanten print elektrische schleusen
durch die wirklich ist also definitiv
eine mauer die fallen muss wann das
passiert ist eine andere frage
unser projekt ist einen torbogen ein
internationales projekt die brasilianer
haben wir schon angefangen
fangen wir an einen halben eimer wasser
und einen halben eimer erde und dann
warten acht kosmische minuten ins leben
gerufen hat diesen ungewöhnlichen
austausch ein verein aus der schweiz
es gibt reis projekte der ort wo das
thema interkulturalität und grappa und
mut und grenze verbindet mit natur dort
wo man nimmt das kontroverses thema -
wie eine grenze damit wurde das schaffen
und gleichzeitig die jetzt überwinden
also in die mur deren schutzfunktion der
positive funktion trend auch und so ist
das mit jeder spezielle bedeutung für
den fahrer selbst und für die je nach
der fälle sicher dass er statt
bei der arbeit mit den händen kommen
sich also menschen aus ländern er die
sich normalerweise nicht begegnet
israelis und palästinenser die im grunde
auf engstem raum beieinander leben
für mich gibt es sehr wenige
gelegenheiten palästinenser zu treffen
gemeinsame aktivitäten gibt es einfach
nicht das hat bei mir den ausschlag
gegeben zu kommen
ich glaube es ist wichtig jeder israeli
sollte so etwas machen
es gibt viele mauern bei uns die
zerstört werden müssen zwischen
palästinensern und israelis
damit wir zusammen ein besseres leben
haben auch aus der schweiz sind junge
menschen angereist horizont erweiterung
im direkten austausch mit denen die in
ihrer heimat mit fundamentalen
konflikten zu kämpfen haben was ist der
unterschied
mittags wird das wüstenklima
unerträglich zeit für andere arbeit die
an vorurteilen ein workshop über
stereotypen steht an die
palästinensische gruppe hört was wir
annahmen über irland im raum sind sie
sind terroristen sie sind besetzt von
israel schikaniert konflikte krieg
islamischer staat und legte ärger hieß
es manches davon stimmt zum beispiel die
stets die märtyrer der kampf manche
hassen israelis weil es viele tote gab
ich würde sagen die mehrheit hast israel
aber hat kein problem mit juden
es ist nicht gegen die religion sondern
gegen die politik
am abend haben die palästinenser bei
ihrem auftritt die chance zur
imagekorrektur
auch gemeinsames essen verbindet
[Applaus]
und danach präsentieren sie einen sketch
über palästinensische
familienverhältnisse über söhne die von
ihren müttern gehätschelt werden auch
wenn sie schlechte schulnoten nach hause
bringen den töchtern der familie geht es
anders du hast deine noten bekommen ich
habe 98 von 100 klassenbeste und damit
bist du zufrieden
wo sind die zwei punkte wo sind die zwei
punkte
weißt du wo dies sind die sind in deinem
iphone mit dem du dich dar und
beschäftigt ein selbstironischer beitrag
der palästinenser eine schöne
überraschung und ein gelungener
schlusspunkt dieses tages am nächsten
morgen geht es mit der mauer weiter
so muss es sollte die konsistenz von
humus haben dicke mauern werden
plötzlich überwindbar in meinem kopf war
es immer so dass protestanten und
katholiken nicht miteinander reden und
nichts miteinander zu tun haben
hier werden sie gute freunde fantastisch
und die schweizer wo sehen sie ihren ort
zwischen all den nationen und
konfessionen wie sprachen und
mentalitäten ein volk trennen können
das werden sie am abend den anderen
teilnehmern erklären fürs dinner haben
sie sich auf ein altbewährtes rezept
geeinigt das feuer dafür entfachen
andere ich bin manchmal ein bisschen
schüchtern
ich will hier aus der komfortzone heraus
und neue dinge entdecken ich bin nicht
so gut darin anderes essen zu probieren
das versuche ich immer der schweizer
abend bringt die erhoffte
herausforderung käsefondue in der wüste
bei fast 40 grad
[Musik]
sie wächst jeden tag ein bisschen ihre
mauer aus lehm und in der freizeit gibt
es gelegenheit kontakte zu vertiefen die
sonst sehr unwahrscheinlich wäre was
jetzt kommt nach diesem programm ist
genauso wichtig ich werde auch später
noch dinge von ihr erfahren
mauern bauen um brücken zu schaffen
eine reiseerfahrung die wohl noch lange
nachhallt
[Musik]